miranda lambert gets emotional on stage  the 32 year old singer was performing  her hit song the house that built me at  her show in Hartford Connecticut on  Friday when she spotted a sign in the  audience that belonged to a fan in the  military  the sign read quote three combat tours  and your voice was the last thing I  listened to every night Thank You  Miranda attempted to finish the song  through her tears but mouths I can't do  it  so her fans happily carried on for her  Miranda has had many memorable moments  on her keeper of the flame tour on  Sunday she instagrammed this shot of a  little boy getting down on one knee with  an engagement ring the country crooner  shared her answer to the sweet gesture  in the caption writing I said yes but he  has to wait 25 years this sweet boy  Sebastian is a little gentleman  you